[Music]
now the big story of the week is of
course the war that is erupting in the
Middle East following the terror attacks
by Hamas on Israel at the weekend I'm
joined Now by Douglas muray uh our
columnist and Paul wood former BBC world
affairs respondent and a frequent
contributor to The Spectator um and uh I
think we'll get into the Middle East
question uh second after with you Paul
after I talked to Douglas a little bit
about his piece in the magazine this
week um the headline of which is uh
Britain must stand up against those who
support Hamas and uh sorry to give away
the ending Douglas but I'm going to do
it um uh you say that you have a
challenge for rishy sunx SW bravman K
stama and the rest of them uh don't just
say you stand against Terror show it uh
don't just say you stand beside Israel
show it uh the treat these people by
which you mean people in Britain who
Express support for Hamas uh as we did
the supporters of Isis take their
passports strip their citizenship
forcibly remove them from this country
um I think a lot of people are agreeing
with you certainly from the reaction
online there's a lot of anger about what
seemed to be celebration celebrations in
London about Terror uh in the Middle
East um however let me put it to you
that it might be trickier than it was
with Isis to uh identify Hamas
supporters because the issue is somewhat
muddled by people who support Palestine
and I don't think you're going to
propose throwing them out of the
country no so if I answer your question
if you have open supporters of a
terrorist group and hamaz has been a
prescribed terrorist entity in the UK
for some years now prescribed in its
entirety if you have Sam Hamas
supporters in the UK my suggestion is
the UK does not either want or need them
it's also not that difficult we have
senior members of Hamas living in the UK
former members of the senior military
leadership of hamaz living in the UK
this is the UK's shame it isn't for the
British government or any other
government to tell the Israeli
government how they should respond to
the massacre of their civilians but I do
think it's important to just bear in
mind that we can in countries like
Britain or should keep our own house in
order I see no reason why Britain should
have for so many years been a retirement
home for members of the Revolutionary
Islamic government in Teran one of whom
as I wrote about in the magazine
recently lives in Harrow I see no reason
why hamas's backers should live in the
UK and I don't see any reason why their
supporters should live in the UK after
Jews have been massacred for being Jews
by Hamas in this Isis likee fashion
treat the the people who support that as
we would the supporters of Isis and if
you can't remove their citizenship and
expel them from the UK at least
prosecute them and imprison them under
the 2006 terrorism act for the
glorification of Terror look at what
happened outside Israeli Embassy in
London the other night crowds of
hundreds of people and again yes there
is a blurry line here because a lot of
people hide behind the idea that they're
supporters of the Palestinian people
when in fact they're just haters of the
Jewish people but look at the people who
turned out the other night before Israel
had done anything in terms of
retaliation against hamz hundreds and
hundreds of people notably young people
uh who were outside the Israeli Embassy
which had to be boarded up and they were
screaming their hatred of Israel well
what were they doing were they
preemptively opposing an Israeli
backlash no of course not they were
rejoicing in the massacre of Israeli
citizens and as I say in the pieace this
has erupted all across Britain we have
people in Brighton talking about how
beautiful the massacre of Jews is in
Israel and being applauded by crowds we
see in other countries other democracies
the same the same way in which people
have used our system and taken rights
they would never give us in return what
about the people in Sydney outside the
Sydney Opera House again after after the
massacres before any retaliation
chanting gas the Jews in Sydney Israel
has its problems but we in the western
democracies have ours and our main one
is that we have people in our countries
who celebrate Terror and I say get them
all out well I I I I understand entirely
what you're saying and I agree with it
to a large extent but I just think there
may be a difficult to sort of carry on
in this muddling point there may be
different laws that would need to be
used here um one would obviously be
Terror legislation and Hamas is a
terrorist prescribed terrorist group um
but the other thing we have to use would
be hate laws uh and I think there you
get into difficult territory well hate
laws are all weak I don't an
law I don't particular believe in hate
laws I think hate laws are a sort of
watery thing that that lacks and um sup
governments imposed because they
couldn't just impose the rule of law as
it existed
um so I'm not very interested in in hate
laws I am interested in the
glorification of Terror and the and the
and the proposition that people should
be allowed to support terrorism in your
country let me put it this way um on the
let's take something like an extremely
rare but awful thing like for instance
the Christ Church mosque Massacre some
years ago in New Zealand imagine if
after that Massacre um there had been a
protest outside the embassies of New
Zealand around the world of people
celebrating the Lone Wolf gunman who
went and shot shot up that mosque would
we be see saying well they're just
expressing a sort of you know a a right
to free expression um or or maybe
they're objecting to the New Zealand
government's potential to have a
backlash against no we would say quite
rightly well these people are obviously
glorifying the terrorist we all know
that it would happen if it was that way
round we all know that so why is it that
the Jewish people have to be the one
people in the world who are expected to
be massacred and to have to respond with
equinity towards that and when they're
taunted on the Streets of London and
other Capital Cities across Europe are
meant to just sit back back and accept
it we didn't take that view with Isis we
didn't take it with Al-Qaeda we
shouldn't take it with
Hamas uh another uh debate that sort of
springing up uh on the domestic reaction
here in Britain uh is this issue of
projecting uh Israeli Flags onto British
government buildings or or flying
Israeli flags from British government
public buildings I wonder how you feel
about that I note that the uh Muslim
Council of uh mosques in London has
written to the government um expressing
its horror at that which I suppose is
only to be expected but I think a lot of
people feel and perhaps they're right
that uh public buildings shouldn't be
used for the flying of any flag other
than the British flag oh well here's the
thing though isn't it after the after
the B Clan massacres in France it was
almost thear for people to say uh to to
fly uh French flags and thank goodness
we did an attempt to show a weak attempt
but an attempt to show
solidarity um in fact when when other
attacks have happened against across
Western democracies it's become a sort
of Norm to do that you may like that or
you may not but here's the thing why why
should it be the case that I mean again
hardly surprising when we're talking
about the MCB but why should it be the
case sort of lower down the food chain
as it were that people would say yes of
course we must show solidarity if it's
if it's the French who are massacred by
islamist barbarians but if it's the
Israelis who are massacred by islamist
barbarians who's to say whether we
should fly the flag of the country that
suffered I I think if you've set the
precedent of trying to show unanimity
and solidarity with friends been
massacred by Barbarians in one country
you should probably do it with the
others as well but as always there's an
Israeli exception and Israeli exception
is that people endlessly think oh maybe
it's going to be divisive it's only
divisive in the UK because we've let in
an awful lot of people who support
terrorism when it's done by the
terrorists of groups like Hamas against
the Jewish Nation so so no I mean I
think that anyone who who sort of has a
sudden problem with that now should have
had it had a bigger problem with it
earlier on and I think if they have a
problem with it now when it comes to the
flag of Israel it tells us much more
about themselves than it does about
Israel yes well let's let's move on to
uh the question of what's or the
questions about what's going on um in
Israel and and The Holy Land um Paul
I'll come to you you've got a excellent
typically excellent piece in this week's
magazine uh in which you speak to
various people who do know a lot about
this uh and the big questions everyone
everyone started asking as soon as this
happened was the involvement of Iran the
extent of Iranian involvement can you
tell us a little bit about what you were
able to
discover we should say first of all
there's no proof of Iranian involvement
and in fact the US uh the White House in
the US says that American intelligence
agencies are looking for that proof but
haven't found it so what you have is
well-founded supposition and the
well-founded supposition says that Hamas
already gets a lot of money from Iran
maybe aund million dollars a year is
well known to have received technical
support from Iran how to build bombs
from everyday materials like pipes and
fertilizer and sugar and also there have
been a lot of meetings between senior
Hamas figures and Senior figures from
the Iranian kuds Force which directs
Iranian foreign policy so Joe Raburn who
used to run Iran policy on the US
National Security Council who's quite a
legendary figure in the Middle East to
people who follow these events says that
to his mind there's absolutely no doubt
that Iran was behind this because the
could force when it has a like Hamas
almost without exception uh directs that
client uh for any major initiative uh
tells that client like Hamas how it will
be done when it will be done and in
rayburn's view this was done for Iranian
strategic reasion reasons uh not Hamas
strategic reasons and those reasons
would be that Iran doesn't yet have a
nuclear weapon uh needs to uh
Israel and by extension the US needs to
support Hezbollah its militia in Lebanon
to the north and therefore wants to tie
Israel down using Hamas and rather
worryingly his view is that uh this also
means that the Iranians will activate
Hezbollah to attack Israel if it looks
like Hamas will be destroyed and
therefore Hezbollah will be isolated
that for Iran is a strategic imperative
all of that does make perfect sense but
there is as yet no proof of
it um another interesting point that
comes out of your piece uh is uh one
Hamas figure uh suggesting uh almost
sort of accidentally suggesting but
suggesting that uh the attack was not
entirely in their control uh can you
explain a little bit more about
that this is assama hamdan who's a very
senior member of Hamas a member of their
polit Bureau who I must say seemed
almost taken aback by what had happened
and scrambling to catch up and you can
imagine that this was something kept
very close to the military wing of Hamas
in its planning and then spokesman and
politicians like him have to run to
catch up and justify it uh I get a
stream of Hamas press releases on my
phone the latest of which says that
there were no atrocities this is the
Western media making things up this is
the Israelis making things up these of
course are absurd lies there was mass
murder um it's been well documented and
yet Hamas seeks to deny it um in his
view this was a military operation
against military targets and as he told
me the Israelis are playing up the
civilian casualties because they are
embar about the extent to which there
was a total collapse of their army
around Gaza and there was in fact a
collapse it was 12 hours 24 hours before
um some of the Israeli towns kutes that
were under attack uh got help from the
Army um he's pointed out um some videos
such as a Hamas fighter apparently
asking permission to take food from an
Israeli house a Hamas fighter apparently
telling a woman and her two children we
are Muslim we will not hurt you again
the uh the Hamas media machine is
pushing out those videos this
morning um but ultimately and this is
the justic justification you get from
from people I've been phoning all around
the region um we've been killed uh
there's a double standard here
Palestinians have been constantly killed
and when we hit back uh everybody
sympathizes with Israel what about the
Palestinian Dead uh he also said
something very interesting um about uh
Hamas being forced into doing this
because of the rapid pace of settlement
in the West Bank which in his view made
the possibility um of a Palestinian
State too remote ever to be achievable
and he almost felt this was the last
chance to do something about that now to
those who who disbelieve that particular
argument I also had a very similar
argument from a former head of mosad the
Israeli spy agency danom who said look
Netanyahu had a mellian policy of
cynically building up Hamas in order to
weaken the PLO which is the main
interlocutor with Israel there are no
talks with Hamas there are talks with
the PLO Netanyahu wanted to the
possibility of a Palestinian State and
gambled and made a terrible mistake in
building up Hamas in order to do
that so I wanted to ask you about uh
Israel making terrible mistakes uh I
mean you put in your piece uh the
Israelis will respond as they see fit it
isn't for non- Israelis to give them
advice and I I see that point um but
also if we feel Israel Ally may be
making a great mistake uh in its
response may even be falling into a trap
possibly even a Iranian set trap uh is
there not some uh validity to the
argument that by uh reacting as
violently as as they seem to be reacting
uh they are only uh you know people talk
about mowing the the grass in in Gaza um
they're only creating the conditions for
it to for it to grow back even more ugly
well first of all I don't agree with the
proposition that Israel has done
anything sign significant or anything
significantly bloody to date and I can
certainly say with absolute
certainty uh that no Israeli soldier has
yet gone in and mass gang raped and then
uh stabbed and beheaded uh women in the
Gaza we're not dealing with the endless
issue of this particularly British
fetish this it's weird a fetish about
proportionality and conflict if there
was proportionality and conflict then it
would seem that we would have to allow
the Israelis to go and gang rape and
behead uh the same number of women and
children as the f as the so-called
Fighters and militants the terrorists of
Hamas did in Israel so Israel hasn't
responded with
1% of the barbarism that was shown on
Israeli territory last Saturday not a
bit of it what Israel does have to do is
to reassert its own um
impenetrability its own um
impermeability and that is what one of
the many things that suffered such a
blow at the weekend the the uh belief
that Israeli intelligence is all knowing
took a huge hit the idea that the IDF is
endlessly able to defend the Israeli
people against all enemies took a
massive hit the idea that Tech uh can
can stand in for human beings at border
crossings and so on took a huge hit the
technological prowess and much more has
taken a huge hit so the most important
thing I should think that Israel would
need to do is to is to build those uh
things even if they are myths back up uh
and it should be allowed to do so uh
that might well include doing things
which uh um people sitting comfortably
in other Western democracies think they
oughtn't to do but I would have thought
that if and again by proportion of
population if if some tens of thousands
of British people were massacred at the
weekend at a music festival and house to
house in small towns uh in a part of our
country I think we would be quite tired
of people who said they were friends
saying to us now don't overreact chaps
will you don't do anything bad hold it I
mean there's something so insulting
about the way in which people think as I
said earlier that the the the the one
Jewish Nation the world is the one
nation that is expected to just suck
suck suck such things up William hay did
it in the times the other day don't fall
for this trap chaps um well there are
lots of things that Israel could do uh
and uh I I will it'll be very
interesting in the weeks ahead whether
people remember the initial atrocities
that will have cause the war to come and
keep them in mind or whether those same
people end up being the people people
who particularly in Britain always end
up saying oh proportionality we showed
no proportionality in conflicts we've
had in the UK in the past and when
whenever Britain has been attacked what
do you think it meant in the second
world war when people sent home postcard
saying we didn't take many prisoners
today so no the endless urging of
restraint on Israel is an endless urging
that the International Community does
because Israel is the only country in
the world never allowed to win a
war that's why by the way you have the
situation in the Gaza you have all the
international idiots telling the
Israelis they have to withdraw and then
what happens you give the Palestinians a
statelet and they they give you Hamas
and War uh anyone who thinks the West
Bank is going to be a Palestinian state
is now living with the fairies and it's
not because of the Israelis it's because
the Palestinian Authority hasn't wished
to create a state for decades it never
did it's only ever been interested in
creating a state from The River To The
Sea as they always say it's never been
interested in a two-state solution
Palestinian Authority under two leaders
now has repeatedly turned down every
Israeli offer uh of of peace they
offered 99% of what they wanted just 15
years ago they turned it down again as
AAS Arafat did at Oslo they don't want a
two-state solution they want a one-state
solution and that's a Jewish cleared
Palestinian State Paul I wonder what you
make of Douglas's point there I think
the two-state solution is probably dead
which is a Pity because it's the only
solution which makes sense in the long
run um Israel I think has begun intense
bombing already and will have to go in
on the ground having destroyed the
obvious targets Hamas is this amalgam of
both EST states with government
buildings to bomb and a Guerilla force
and the gorillas have now withdrawn into
the civilian
population uh which is being hit by
Israel now what Hamas did um was a war
crime um murders were committed this is
against international law but Israel is
a state which at least pretends to be
governed by international law and there
one of the suggestions which came out in
the in the horrible 24 hours of chaos
and
confusion um when this happened at the
weekend was a former Israeli General
called guor Island who was the southern
Commander used to be in charge of Gaza
saying that what we should do is go in
and literally poison the wells
97% of gaza's water comes from the
saltwater Wells and it has to be
purified in water purification plants um
gor Island general Island wanted to um
destroy those purification plants saying
everybody will say we're deliberately
causing a humanitarian disaster and we
will be doing that as a means to get our
hostages back and Destroy Hamas well
that would almost certainly be a breach
of international law it would be
Collective punishment and this perhaps
is the kind of trap which Hamas whether
knowingly or unknowingly because Iran
pushed them to do this has set for
Israel a lot of Israeli strategists and
people who thought about this don't want
a reoccupation of the Gaza Strip they
know that that way lies more misery and
more Bloodshed and by the way in the end
Israel is going to have to talk to Hamas
and pro probably is talking to them
already through intermediaries about the
hostages talking through katar um there
is the outlines of a settlement there
it's still the two-state solution
impossible as that seems now it's even
one which so-called moderates in Hamas
this is an organization with moderates
and hardliners like any other it's a
solution that some in Hamas do want
eventually despite the atrocities at the
weekend I I think I'm sorry to disagree
with Paul but greatly respect I think I
I think it's it's it's nonsense to think
there's any such thing as a two-state
solution on the table I don't think it
has been I think that it's been the sort
of thing that uh a certain type Western
politician who who hasn't been following
it very closely thinks always is a
Perpetual answer the truth is is that
nobody wants a Palestinian people the
Arab Nations don't want them if the
jordanians cared about the Palestinian
peoples they would have taken taken them
in uh 50 years ago if the Egyptians
cared about the Palestinian peoples
they'd have taken them in from the Gaza
many years ago the Egyptians don't like
them the jordanians don't want them none
of the other countries in the region
want them but it's very convenient for
them to all make the Palestinians
Israel's problem I see no reason why the
Palestinian peoples have to be Israel's
problem uh as I say the Israeli uh
people have learned a very unpleasant
lesson in the last 17 years now that if
you give the Palestinians ter they will
give you rockets in return and you can
always find people uh like the general
you just cited in the immediate
aftermath of unspeakable atrocities of a
Kind not seen since World War II you can
always find somebody who who who who
will voice a particular vengeful opinion
but that's because there's Vengeance in
the air because an atrocity was
committed and again if this had been
done against the British public if this
had been an attack on Britain I'd have
thought we'd find a lot of vengeful
people here at least I'd hope so I I
think that's quite right Doug I take
that point but I suppose the difference
is uh Britain isn't Israel uh and we are
not surrounded by countries that wish to
um annihilate us uh and so therefore
Israel's response uh you know a Wise
Wise Council might be uh not to respond
uh in in the retaliatory way that a lot
of Israeli Poli not to respond at all I
mean for instance why should Kata be be
be hosting the heads of Hamas why should
Kata not be held
responsible uh one reason I'll tell you
right away is that kataar has managed to
buy up a whole load of influence in
countries like this one nobody will talk
about that what should happen which is
among other things retaliatory strikes
against Hamas leaders who live in Kata
but of course Britain won't do that
because Britain's been
compromised like so many countries so so
I mean a lot of British politicians and
others will say oh Don't Do Anything
That Rocks the boat Israel and among
other things what they mean is we've
lost control of things including our
parts of our financial system we can't
control the British streets so don't you
and Israel do anything that makes a mess
of our streets well again that's not
Israel's problem that's ours it's us
who've been the idiots Paul Douglas says
nobody really wants a Palestinian state
do you think the European Union wants a
Palestinian state it's thrown uh
billions in support uh to Palestine uh
probably I I mean this is in one sense
Douglas is right there is no two-state
solution for the foreseeable future but
in another sense it's the only game in
town and uh for instance Danny at Tom
the former mosad Chief said that with
500,000 settlers now in the West Bank
and more being pushed in by the
Netanyahu government that was an attempt
to make the two State solution
impossible no doubt the Palestinians um
or the p
as in Israel's main negotiating partner
carries a lot of blame for that too but
in yon's view um this was uh Netanyahu
carrying out a long-standing policy of
some Israeli governments to try to Annex
the West Bank and the response from
Hamas um the bloody massacre that we saw
last weekend in the words of the Hamas
spokesman um who talked to me about it
was they felt they they were being
backed into a corner um that's their
calculation um it's innocent people who
who suffer in this um Palestinian
children bleed too on the first day of
Israel's bombing um a family of 19 who
had fled their home because of a warning
shot nearby to another building were in
the building when it was hit by a
missile 19 people dead mostly women and
children um according to the AP reporter
on the scene didn't seem to be a
military Target there of course this is
what happens when Guerilla armies which
is what Hamas is retreating to the
civilian population of course this is
what happens in the builtup slums that
constitute most of Gaza City uh it may
not be um the aim of Israeli policy
although most in the Arab world will
certainly think that it is one of the
dispiriting things in the 24 or 48 hours
after the attack was looking at the Arab
press and seeing almost no coverage of
the Israeli victims people's hearts were
hardened right from the outset and
that's what I got in telephone calls
with people they feel they have their
victims that have always been ignored
and now they're ignoring the Jewish
victims makes you very pessimistic about
any outcome one thing we can say with
absolute certainty is
uh that the soldiers of Israel are not
going to be hiding among civilian
populations and using the populations as
Shields that is exactly what Hamas has
done it's exactly what the fight the
fighter terrorists of Hamas have done
it's their plan so you know there's also
an issue not only of proportionality but
of intentionality and the intention of
Hamas last week was to kill as many
innocent people as possible the
intention of Israel very clear clearly
as has been shown in many engagements is
to kill as few innocent people as
possible that difference might seem
academic to some people but in it lies
everything there's a lot more to talk
about uh but sadly we don't have time um
so uh Douglas and Paul for now thank you
very much for joining spectator
[Music]
TV